hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey I am I am we're
going to watch summer kpop BTS map at
the so persona persona comeback trailer
from top reward tier patron Natali Doran
top of the morning to you Natalie let's
get to it now shall we June hey let's do
it Ireland a heads up if you are brand
new we do cut these up because we often
find that our reactions even for BTS
sometimes get blocked worldwide so
that's why we have to cut the reaction
portion but also we do music video
reactions specifically this guy over at
our patreon page he covers music videos
three times a week
uncut over there and we also do you know
TV show reaction stream along some of
the reaction highlights included as well
as weekly Q&A is but let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
huh cool into the spiders
[Music]
I'm kind of good
[Music]
Dayal
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
as a rap monster right there whoa
[Music]
oh that was badass sad ass man and this
is neat like this is I think the first
BTS I've checked out that is upcoming
this is not even out yet right right
that's coming out in April and that was
rad I wanna try memorize that map of the
soul persona you know I got it in
register like oh this song's called
persona as I was listening to it but I I
really liked it because starting off of
those opening lines of you can't sum up
who he is or you have everything even
generally can't something someone is
just with a few mere words because his
life is about variety and he's saying
like he's being pulled in like different
directions all the time who he should be
what he should be doing it's like
there's always the contrast of something
else that's always happening at every
single moment and this persona they used
sometimes what they put on of like the
image that people have of you and are
you that but are you more than that and
he is it seems like he wants to be able
to express all variety of sides the joys
the highs the lows the dark times the
good times you know it's like you're not
just narrowed into one thing your wide
variety of things so I thought it was
actually really cool just rap about
embracing all the shades yeah no totally
I mean and that's the thing is like in
the style of the song like it's got a
swagger to it and it's got kind of it's
very modern production but it sounds
almost like an older school approach to
the beat almost reminded me of like what
Eminem came back with berserk in a sense
yeah it's got that kind of bombastic yes
ragged doshas quality to it and yeah I
really loved what he was rapping about
partly cuz yeah like his flow is badass
but also it seemed like really lucid and
and personal in a way it's like a lot of
their songs have especially a lot of
their songs as a group have more pop
conventions to the construction of the
lyrics I feel like but this seems like a
really personal statement of him not
only just talking about you know his
worth and quality as a human being but
also even acknowledging the persona that
is RM that is rap monster versus who he
actually is and sort of what that allows
him to do and kind of why that exists I
like the juxtaposition of the first
verse to the second verse cuz in the
first person he's talking about yeah
like I cannot be summed up in just a
couple words and in a couple questions I
can't answer who I haven't probably in a
lifetime I can't answer that and some
these things can be very angsting and
can pull you in all sorts of different
directions and make you very confused
and I love the way that throughout
various songs there they're able to
encompass all those different flavours
yeah and then to come back in the second
half of the song and just really
solidify that confident statement of
just like this is me you know like this
is I'm not embarrassed this anymore like
this is just I'm gonna lay my soul out
there and do my thing yeah that's badass
yeah well it's easy to kind of put
especially a group like who's this
sensationally famous up on this pedestal
especially the lead as if they have to
put up this persona of perfection and a
lot of this was about how he's not
flawless and I really love that element
being flawed is a big part of what makes
him the status of where he's at now like
he needs those flaws in order to be
where he's at such a cool thing
especially when you watch this group
performed like man they're just pitched
as perfect and look at the beam perfect
you know music videos I think we even
commented like these guys get
self-conscious about any yeah yeah yeah
and like in the comments a lot of people
were like no yeah they really they're
done earth about this kind of stuff
they're really open about it you know
yeah I believe it's not the whole group
it's just him there's something about
this that just felt so immediate and
personal I know it's like a promo song
or something like that right yeah or at
least like the leadoff single would be
my guess or something and of course you
know it goes that same BTS music video
the productive like the production of it
was more simple than what they normally
do but it felt less just only Greek like
a lot of times you feel a lot of the
green screen here and I can feel a lot
more set pieces you know yeah well this
felt more like kind of an old school or
an older school hip-hop video to me
where it's just a few locations a couple
lens switches you know some very design
color palettes and visual choices but
ultimately not at least insanely
intricate yeah yeah I love this yeah man
and this is like III really have I don't
I'm not lying when I say this in the
comments and stuff like I really have
come to enjoy BTS you've watched a few
of my own and even though not all of
their music is the kind of stuff I would
throw on you know just when I'm chilling
I cannot wait to hear this again yeah
like this is gonna definitely be one
that goes on some playlists for me
absolutely
well thanks Natalie I know you're gonna
go see BTS and I think
just about a month or so congratulations
there and she's gonna be coming to
America just like Eddie Murphy yeah in
California
you know you got do now that you got to
come on the channel and you got a you
know axis would be to come on the
channel oh boy I mean you got a you got
a knob sorry that you know what you you
got to join us on the channel and react
to some BTS with us and I hope you come
Allah
you know cuddles all around I think
we'll just yeah if we can all like share
a plate on ik hug you know and and me or
maybe a handshake would suffice a fish
fist but we can make I contest subscribe
to the rule and rechecks click the
notification bell and and and and come
on by bond pop